rabbit mq an open source distributed
message broker that works like a post
office in the cloud it was developed in
2007 and written in the erlang
programming language which itself is
famous for powering the open telecom
platform in the beginning apps were
built as monoliths with all concerns
coupled together on a single runtime the
problem is that not everything scales in
parallel differing computational needs
gave rise to the microservice
architecture where every concern has its
own run time that scales independently
rabbitmq is a tool that allows these
microservices to communicate
asynchronously with a variety of
different protocols for example you may
have an app that applies deep learning
photo filters when the user clicks a
button that request goes to a rest api
but instead of processing the image
there it produces a message with the
required data and publishes it to an
exchange the exchange is then
responsible for routing it to one or
more queues which are linked to the
exchange with a binding and routing key
now the message sits in the queue until
it's handled by the consumer which in
this case would be the image processing
server the exchange can route directly
to a specific queue or to multiple cues
with a shared pattern using topics or to
every queue it knows about with fanout
the end result is an architecture that
allows servers to both publish and
subscribe to data thanks to the rabbitmq
middleman to get started install it or
run it in a docker container on port
5672 it also contains a cli tool to
manage and inspect your broker now
create a file in your favorite server
side language and bring in a library
that implements a messaging protocol
like advanced messaging queue protocol
091 this file will send a message and
first needs to connect to rabbitmq on
that connection we can use the create
channel method to declare a cue which
can be named whatever you want cues can
be durable where the metadata is stored
on disk or transient where it's only
stored in memory and now produce a
message by sending a buffer to that
queue go ahead and run the file to
create the queue and send the message
then create another file to receive the
message in real life this could be a
different server on the other side of
the world connect to rabbitmq just like
we did for the publisher then reference
the same queue name on that connection
now use the consume method to receive a
message and run a callback function with
its data now run that file in a separate
terminal to receive the message that's
how a basic queue works but we could
expand on this code by creating an
exchange to manage multiple queues at
the same time a fan out or topic
exchange would allow multiple servers to
subscribe to the same messages but
consume them at different times this has
been rabbitmq in 100 seconds hit the
like button if you want to see more
short videos like this thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one